- How are your Modern Family co-stars?
Do you see them at all?
You guys were a family for what?
- 12 years?
- 11 years.
11 years.
I got the chance to interview Ty and Jesse
for the podcast which was great.
Jesse in person was wonderful.
And then this weekend I saw my dear.
There he is,
there he is.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah, he was a great guest
on the tonight show as well.
Very funny.
- I mean, as good as me?
- No, not as good as you, certainly.
- It's a different experience.
- Different experience.
- It's different.
He actually listens.
- Right, right, right, right.
- It's just different.
- Yeah, I could ask him a question.
- Oh, yeah we know that's (mumbles)
We've done that.
And then I got to see Nolan
this weekend, my baby boy.
Who was all grown up and beautiful.
So I don't see them nearly enough,
but, I mean I do--
- Well, maybe there's a
reunion somewhere in the works,
somewhere down the road.
- Like, your house?
(audience clapping)
- Yeah, I think people would love that.
- Jay Leno's Garage with
a cast of Modern Family.
- Works for me.
- I can make that happen.
(audience cheering)